[Music]
this morning amanda gorman will become
the youngest known
inaugural poet when she performs at the
59th
presidential inauguration as the
nation's first youth poet laureate
you may recognize gorman she's performed
five commissioned poems
for cbs this morning over the past few
years today
she'll deliver her original composition
the hill we climb
at the capitol in front of joe biden
kamala harris
and the entire nation we spoke to her
ahead of her big moment
in the declaration's pages we write
in new order for the ages where out of
many
we are one bright as a son and bold
as an eagle a nation of all people
by all people for all people
amanda gorman has written poems for
historic occasions
now she's making history herself
how cool is this um it's amazing
especially at my age no one really gets
to say at 22 i am the inaugural poet
gorman says she researched the speeches
of abraham lincoln
and dr martin luther king jr as she
began writing
and then on the wednesday in which we
saw the insurrection at the capitol
that was the day that the poem really
came to life and i really put petal to
the metal
did that change the poem for you
definitely i wanted it to be a message
of
hope and unity and i think that
wednesday for me really just
underscored how much that was needed but
to not
turn a blind eye to the cracks that
really need to be filled
gorman was named the nation's first
youth poet laureate
at 19. at 16 she was youth poet laureate
of los angeles i sing a neighborhood
anthem for the silence where she was
raised by a single mom
joan an english teacher the anthem will
sing
amanda drop your eyes but do not drop
your volume
and writing became her way over a
daunting
obstacle i had a speech impediment and
so i couldn't use my voice
then i would author my voice on the page
so it's really been
a godsend and a lifeline for me how did
you overcome it
poetry and you know to put it short
spoken word became my own type of
pathology
and so once i arrived at the point in my
life in high school where i said
you know what writing my poems on the
page
isn't enough for me i have to give them
breath in life i
have to perform them as i am that was
the moment that i was able to grow
past my speech impediment gorman who had
particular trouble with the letter
r also used music as therapy
my favorite thing to practice was the
song aaron burr
sir from hamilton because it was
jam-packed with ours and i said
if i can keep up with you know leslie in
this track then i am on my way to being
able to say
this r and a poem
we wild we want we stunt
we strive we hustle we hungry we run
free here we come we
one country we ain't done see so how do
you feel when you are
performing these poems when i am on
stage i
feel electric i feel like i could
breathe fire
like i am summoning the energy not only
of myself but of
my ancestors but the point of protest
isn't winning it's holding fast to the
promise of freedom
even when fast victory isn't promised
poetry is a weapon it is an instrument
of social change
and poetry is one of the most political
arts out there because it demands that
you
rupture and destabilize the language in
which you're working with inherently
you are pushing against the status quo
and so for me
it's always existed in that tradition of
truth-telling
today she will do her truth-telling on
the steps of the united states capital
how do you prepare for something like
this one of the preparations that i do
do always whenever i perform is i
say a mantra to myself which is i am the
daughter of
black riders who are descended from
freedom fighters
who broke through chains and changed the
world they call me
and that is the way in which i prepare
myself with a beauty that needs to get
done
do you say that inside your head or do
you say it aloud
if i can and i'm not going to scare
anybody off i always say it out loud so
i'm usually like in a bathroom or a
dressing room
but if you know backstage and i imagine
if i'm like standing next to
joe biden i might like keep it
have here worry about craziness i don't
want secret service to think you know
amanda's gone
nobody mayday i know she is so amazing
amanda says she battled that speech
impediment all the way into college she
graduated harvard in the spring she's
working on a bunch of books she's got a
children's book called change things
that comes out in september
long term plans 2036 running for
president she says i believe hitting me
says that she already has a hashtag
commanda in chief i like it
listen i got a great story for you
anthony because i told oprah that you
were doing her yeah
oprah said she reached out to amanda
because when maya did her speech
uh at the inaugural bill clinton right
oprah bought maya a coat
that's a pretty blue coat so she reached
out to amanda and said i'd like to
carry on the tradition amanda said i
already have a coat it's in my favorite
color
so oprah got her these gold hoop
earrings and a ring that's shaped like a
bird cage
as a nod to maya i know how the how the
uh caged bird
sings yeah so today when you're watching
her we'll see that that's really
exciting